[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
128 of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel and I'm here
with my colleague as always,
Melanie Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm
doing good, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
doing all right.
It's a Monday.
MELANIE WARRICK: I
know and I'm back
from Mexico City, where I was
at the Understanding Risk Forum
Conference, which was
pretty impressive.
MARK MANDEL: That was good?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,
it was really great.
MARK MANDEL: That's awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: We talked a
lot about disaster recovery
actually, which was
really interesting.
Yeah.
And how to use tech to help
with disaster recovery.
But it's good to be back.
MARK MANDEL: Indeed.
This week we have
Cassie Kozyrkov
joining us to talk about
decision intelligence.
It's a super interesting
episode actually.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, very much so.
MARK MANDEL: And we also
have Cool things of the week
but we finally will finish up
with our question of the week--
talking about how you can secure
your Google Cloud Platform
account using a YubiKey, or
basically a physical device.
MELANIE WARRICK: I like
anything around security.
So as you mentioned,
Mark, we're going
to start out with the
cool things of the week.
And this week, we
wanted to bring up
that TPUs are now available in
beta on Cloud Machine Learning
Engine.
So if you want to play
around with the TPU,
you don't have to sign up to
get approved to have access.
You can just go onto the
Machine Learning Engine
and set that up.
We have a link to the
information about this
on our show notes, as always.
And one of the
links in particular
will tell you exactly
how to set this up
and also how to use
a resonant model.
It gives a nice, little example
of setting up a resident
and running that on the
Machine Learning Engine.
So check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
As per always I have to
talk about Kubernetes.
Kubernetes 1.10 is now
generally available and ready
for the enterprise.
I love that tag line.
Not only are you getting the
lovely new features of 1.10,
there's a bunch of
new features for gke,
including shared virtual
private clouds, so VPCs.
I know there's been a lot
of requests for those,
as well as node order repairs,
regional persistent disks,
and a few other fun things.
So if you're looking to
upgrade to 1.10, now you can.
MELANIE WARRICK: We
also want to mention
that the ultramem Google
Compute Engine machine
types are now available.
And those are basically a
family of memory optimized
virtual machine
instances and they
come with a lot more memory.
MARK MANDEL: A lot.
MELANIE WARRICK: What was it?
MARK MANDEL: 961 gigabytes.
MELANIE WARRICK: 1,922
gigabytes of memory and the 80--
well you mentioned the
961 gigabytes of memory
and that's in the ultramem 40.
And it goes up to
ultramem 160 and it's
got 3,844 gigabytes of memory.
MARK MANDEL: And 160 CPUs.
MELANIE WARRICK: And I know from
training models in the past,
you love memory.
If you can run a bunch
of stuff in memory,
it's pretty fantastic.
There's many reasons and
many cases out there--
MARK MANDEL: Really
big red assistance.
Just a really--
MELANIE WARRICK: Really big--
loading all of the data up--
MARK MANDEL: One machine.
MELANIE WARRICK: Doing
all the calculations.
MARK MANDEL: It'll be fine.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It'll be fantastic.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK: No
more parallel computing.
Not really but--
MARK MANDEL: Bigger machines.
Awesome.
Finally, there was an
article that came out
on the 15th of May titled,
"Increase performance
by reducing costs with the
new App Engine scheduler."
What's cool about this
is you don't actually
have to do anything if
you're using App Engine.
MELANIE WARRICK:
That's even better.
MARK MANDEL: That's
it's even better.
So basically the new
scheduler improves
the number of cold starts by
30% but also reduces cost by 7%.
So all-around goodness.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
And also an average
of 5% reduction
in median and tailed
request latencies.
It's all about saving time.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
MELANIE WARRICK: Saving
time is the best.
All right, Mark, I think
it's time that we go and talk
with Cassie.
MARK MANDEL: Let's go to that.
MELANIE WARRICK:
This week, we're
excited to have join
us Cassie Kozyrkov who
is one of our teammates.
And she's here today to talk to
us about decision intelligence.
Welcome to the podcast.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
Delighted to be here.
MELANIE WARRICK: Well,
I'm glad you're here.
So Cassie, I know we've talked
a little bit about this--
what decision intelligence is.
But before we even
get into what that is,
can you tell us a little
bit about yourself?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Sure.
I service chief decision
scientist for Google Cloud.
And what I'm really
passionate about
is data science plus
decision making together.
And you can think of me as a
sort of reformed statistician
if you will, that's my
core academic background
supplemented with psychology,
economics, and neuroscience.
And my experience
before this role
was consulting Academia
and data science.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
So why are you passionate
about decision making?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
Well, see anything we
think we know-- our
knowledge, our insights,
our impressions they
only really begin
to matter when they
drive our actions.
So decisions are the
way that we interact
with the world around us.
And while some
people might think
of decision making as the
way that you meet your goals
or beat your
competition, there's
really so much more
to it than that.
Businesses and people who don't
know how to make decisions
well are in danger of having
really large, negative impact
on the world around them.
So I think of decision making
as a way in which we can build
a better world for all of us.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
MARK MANDEL: So what exactly
is decision intelligence
engineering?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Well, I like
to think of it as data science
plus, plus if you will--
well, machine
learning plus, plus.
It focuses on the applied
aspects of data science.
Making decisions with
data and how to do that.
Building processes for getting
from the conception of an idea
to a data science
project running reliably
and automating decision making.
What
MELANIE WARRICK:
Is data inspired?
What does that mean?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
Data inspired is
a sort of joke about
a serious subject.
It's a term that we
use around Google
a lot that has to do
with not being data
driven when you think you are.
Now, let me give
you an example--
if I tell you that a hotel has
a star rating of 4.2 and then
I ask you whether or not you'd
like to stay at that hotel.
I have destroyed your
ability to be data driven.
You can't use that data, that
4.2, to make your decision.
That's because if
you really wanted
to stay at this hotel all
along, you will look at that 4.2
and you will say, hey,
that's more than 4.0.
Sure, I'll go for it.
Whereas if in your
heart of hearts,
you really wanted
to keep looking
and go for a different
hotel, you're going to say,
what am I some kind of animal
to stay at a hotel that's
got less than 4.5 stars?
And so the way that you
interact with that information
will be driven by
the decision you
want to make all along,
by your unconscious biases
and not by the data itself.
So in order for you
to be data driven,
the data has to
drive the decision.
And so you have to
have thought about what
it takes to make you want
to stay at the hotel versus
not before you see that 4.2.
Where was your cutoff?
Was it 4.1?
Was it 3.5?
Commit to that early and up
front, then look at the data.
That's data driven.
Whereas data inspired is where
we, like wales encountering
plankton, swim around
in some numbers
and then we reach some emotional
tipping point and we decide.
And sure, there are numbers
near that decision somewhere.
It's just not the numbers
that drove the decision.
So that decision would be,
at best, data inspired.
MARK MANDEL: It sounds
like as you talk through it
a lot of that is
behavioral sciences as well
as data sciences.
Why have those two
really combined here?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Yeah, so I
think of decision intelligence
engineering as
augmenting data science
with the behavioral and
managerial sciences.
And the key here is
that in order for us
to let the data
drive the decision,
that decision context has
to be framed up front.
So the decision maker has to
understand what it actually
takes to get them to want to
do one thing versus another.
And so that process
where they actually
think through how they want
to make their decision,
that process isn't
taught in data science.
That's not an
engineering process.
That's taught in behavioral
psychology and in economics.
That's about incentive
design, cost benefit analysis,
risk assessment.
All of the subjects that are not
covered in typical data science
courses.
MELANIE WARRICK: They
definitely play a role in--
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK: --terms of
those types of decisions.
So for the decision
makers, and I
know the decision
makers can span
the company, but
especially those
who are more on the
leadership side of things--
how should they
approach decision
making so it's data driven?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So they
have to frame their decision
context carefully and
thoughtfully at the beginning.
So here's where
you want to start--
let's take that hotel example.
Your first move is
to think about how
you would want to make the
decision if you could not
get any more information.
You know nothing
about the hotel.
Are you going to stay
in it by default or not?
So you have to commit to
your default action upfront.
Your next move then,
and this is where
it takes a lot of training and
mental flexibility on the part
of the decision maker, is to
think about what information
you would want.
What information you would
use if you could have access
to everything that's
true about the universe,
you were all-knowing.
So you have to think about
framing your decision
context under full information.
Would you want to use the
star rating on average?
Would you want to know
how many bad reviews?
Or have people written
about bed bugs?
Or what would you actually
want to know about this hotel
in order to make your decision?
And where is your
cutoff-- if you
are using that average stars
review, if you knew for a fact
it was 4.1 what would
you do about it?
If you knew it was for a fact
4.9 what would you do then?
Where is your cutoff?
And you don't need
data to do this.
You need imagination
but it's not easy.
And then after you've dealt
with full information you
ask yourself, can I
actually have access
to this information
I've requested or am
I forced to deal with only
a partial view of reality?
Not the facts I wanted
but a pale shadow of them.
If I only have
partial information,
then I'm making the
decision under uncertainty--
then it is statistical.
And then what I need to
do is I need to realize
that I could make a mistake.
Uncertainty means well,
mistakes are possible now.
And I could leave my
default action incorrectly
but I might also stay on my
default action incorrectly.
And then I have to
think about how I
would balance the risks there.
Which one is worse
and how much worse?
How much risk am I
willing to accept?
And only after we've
done all of that can we
go to a statistician
and have them help
us move the rest of
the way through making
that data driven decision.
MELANIE WARRICK: Data science
I know plays a role here.
How do you define data science?
What is that?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
So a lot of folks
think that the areas
within data science--
descriptive analytics;
statistical inference,
or statistics for short,
and machine learning
and AI are defined by the
algorithms used in them
but that's not true.
If you're a creative,
smart data scientist,
you realize that you can
use any algorithm for any
of these subdisciplines.
And so really the
difference between them
is how they are used
for decision making.
Data science is just
the umbrella term that
contains these three things.
How they're used for decision
making is what separates them.
So let's have a look.
If we're making no
decisions, then we're
doing descriptive analytics.
Descriptive analytics
is all about asking
what is here in my
data so that either we
can make a fact based decision
or we can just get inspired.
If we are making one or
a few important decisions
under uncertainty--
decisions with no do overs,
should we launch this product?
Yes or no?
Then that's a
statistical inference,
statistics for short.
And if we are stitching
a recipe for making
a lot of repeated decisions,
then that is machine learning.
Data science is the umbrella
that connects all three
of these together.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So from a decision
intelligence perspective,
why should we be excited
about machine learning?
What does that
bring to the table?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
So machine learning
is all about algorithmically
creating recipes
for making decisions.
And we call those
recipes, "models."
All that really means is
that machine learning well,
it's the thing
labeler essentially.
That's what it is,
to put it bluntly.
The reason that we
should be excited
about that approach for
thing labeling as opposed
to the traditional one
where a programmer has
to think really hard
about the problem
and then hand-craft the code
that takes us from the inputs
to the label that
we want is that some
tasks it's really,
really hard to come up
with the instructions for.
So think about if you see
a picture of an animal
and you just know
that it's a cat.
What does your brain
actually do to those pixels
to get that label?
It's really hard to
describe what you've done.
And so how could you possibly
write those instructions
explicitly for the computer?
Your only hope is to try
to get that recipe stitched
by giving the computer a
whole bunch of examples
and then saying to an algorithm,
a machine learning algorithm,
figure it out.
Make that recipe for me
because I can't express it.
I think of this as
giving us the ability
to automate the ineffable.
And that's why we should
really be excited.
This is a fundamental
leap in human progress.
This unlocks a
whole class of tasks
that we couldn't
get computers to do
because we couldn't explain to
the computer how to do them.
Now we explained not with
instructions but with examples.
MELANIE WARRICK: I see
machine learning always spoken
about in conjunction with
artificial intelligence.
And I know I have my own
perspective on this space
but I'd like to hear how you
define artificial intelligence.
How do you define AI?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So I
see AI typically spoken
about one of two different ways.
The first option is to stay
true to how that term has
been used throughout history.
And that means staying true to
how it was defined in the '50s.
And sometimes I like to
joke that that version is
whatever would have
impressed folks in the '50s.
And whenever we end up building
that impressive thing--
maybe our calculators today
might have impressed them.
But then we just
moved the goalposts
further and further away.
So that version is a little
unhelpful for my taste
because it's both
everything and nothing.
The other version, what industry
is really excited about--
everyone wants to
get into AI today.
That's the version
that I prefer as well.
And to be more formal, that
version is deep learning.
That is that part
of machine learning
where the recipe of the
model could not possibly be
stitched by a human programmer.
There is no way
to solve that task
except to go with examples.
So a difference and to give
you a quick example here--
I like wine.
And I have without
any kind of data
got a little heuristic
that goes something
like check the
color of the bottle.
If it's white don't bother.
If it's red, let's talk.
That kind of heuristic.
And I imagine if I use data
to try to predict whether I'll
like a new bottle of wine,
use machine learning,
I might do a little better than
this hacky recipe that I have.
The point is my recipe does OK.
I can kind of take
a stab at that task.
That would be a
machine learning task.
Whereas this version
of look at the image
and figure out whether
there's a cat in it or not,
I have no idea how I would even
start expressing that recipe.
So that one is AI.
I would have to use
an algorithm that's
flexible enough and
sophisticated enough
to just figure that
out from examples
even though I can't express it.
And that would be deep learning.
MELANIE WARRICK: I like
that you're using recipe.
Definitely a great
way to express it.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: I used to use
model like people in my field
do.
Model this, model that.
And then I got feedback that
not everyone actually knows
what that word "model" means.
MELANIE WARRICK: It's true.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: But recipe,
I think we can all get behind.
MARK MANDEL: But
sounds like then
that AI is more applicable
to decision intelligence
to ML or--
like where does
AI fit into this?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So actually
what I prefer for people to do
is to start with what
task they want to perform,
if they're going to apply it.
And it's enough for you to
figure out whether or not
you need machine learning.
And if it so happens that
you need the deep learning
algorithm, you will end
up with an AI application.
And if you didn't need
it, the right process
might have you use a much
more lightweight algorithm.
But you don't need to know in
advance whether it's the AI
kind of machine learning.
You just need a good process
for machine learning.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
then off of that note,
what are some common
mistakes that you're
seeing leaders make with AI
or companies make with AI?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: When we
talk about machine learning
I think we do the field a
little bit of a disservice
because we make it
sound like there's
only one discipline there.
When actually there are
two machine learnings
and they're two completely
different disciplines.
So maybe we should break them up
into research machine learning
and applied machine learning.
And my analogy for this
is the humble microwave.
If I said that I were
a microwave specialist,
microwave expert
you might think I'm
a person who builds microwaves.
Maybe you'd think I
know how to innovate
with microwaves in a kitchen--
build recipes
involving microwaves.
You might not realize
which one I am.
So these are the two
different disciplines.
The research machine learning
is about building the microwaves
as general purpose tools
for everyone to use.
And see, you need quite a lot of
education to get into that game
because how are you going
to build a better algorithm
or for that matter, a better
microwave than the one that
exists already if you have
no idea how this one works,
you've never seen
its wiring diagram?
So for research
machine learning,
you need a lot of background.
It's all about building
those algorithms.
On the other hand, if you're
going to innovate in recipes
and actually use these things
at scale in an industrial scale
kitchen, you need to
know a bunch of things
but they're not the same as
what you would need in order
to build the microwave.
I mean think about this.
How does a chef know that
the microwave works and is
what they need?
Certainly not by reading
the wiring diagram.
I'm pretty sure that
most chefs don't do that.
Instead, it's by actually
checking that it works
and it does what
they want it to do.
And in addition to having
a microwave that works--
tasting what it
outputs, they need
to have thought
about what they want
to serve to their customers.
They need to have thought
about their ingredients.
about their process
and how they've done
their taste tests
and how they run
that whole kitchen.
So there's a huge
science on that side.
And the mistake
that leaders make
is they don't see that there's
a difference between these two.
And so what they try to do is
they try to build themselves
a machine learning
team, an AI team.
And they staff that
entirely with researchers.
And that is exactly
the same as you
want to run an
industrial scale kitchen
and the only people
you hire are the folks
who've built microwaves
their whole lives.
Those folks might not know
anything about cooking.
Might have no empathy
for restaurant customers.
Now sometimes
businesses luck out.
They've heard a bunch of
researches and things turned
out OK.
That's a happy accident.
That's because in addition
to the core skills taught
in a PhD, those
researchers ended up
developing a love
for the application.
That's a whole
other set of skills
that they got by accident.
And as our site reliability
folks say at Google,
hope is not a strategy.
Don't hope that your
researchers will just develop
that capability out of nowhere.
Instead, hire for
the applied kitchen.
Hire for the end-to-end process.
Hire leaders who
know their business.
Hire engineers who can
process and visualize
those ingredients--
that data well for you.
Hire statisticians who
can do that taste test
and check that it works
on the other side.
And maybe you don't even
need the researchers
because Academia, Google
Cloud, and other places
like that are building
those microwaves for you.
So as long as you know
where to go and shop for one
and take it and try
it out, maybe you
don't need to reinvent the
wheel-- build that thing
from scratch yourselves.
So leaders please don't start
by hiring the researcher only
and hoping that everything's
going to be great.
MELANIE WARRICK: I like that
you brought up end-to-end.
It's a common major
challenge trying
to figure out how to actually
make the full pipeline work.
But all these kitchen and food
analogies are making me hungry.
Mark.
MARK MANDEL: So we talked a
little about common mistakes.
But where then should
leaders actually start?
What's a great starting point?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Before you
even hire any one leaders
you have a job to do.
This process should
always start with you.
And in machine learning
the first thing
you need to think
about is what outputs
is your system going to make?
Machine learning is
essentially a thing labeler.
So what do you need labeled?
And if you can't even think
of what you need labeled,
diving right into
machine learning
is a little too soon for you.
Maybe you want to do some
descriptive analytics
and hopefully we'll get a
chance to chat about that soon.
But imagine in
this wine example,
you want to build yourself
a wine classifier.
Well, what do you want the
system to output for you?
Maybe I'll like it
or I won't like it
on a new bottle of wine.
You have to be able to say
what those outputs should be.
And then you need to think about
how you would measure success
and what mistakes are possible.
And there are really a lot of
options here, decision makers.
Maybe you're after accuracy.
Or mistakes are equally bad
as far as you're concerned.
Missing out on a good
bottle or getting
a bad bottle, same to you.
But maybe you are a starving
grad student, I've been there,
and money is really precious.
And you're quite happy to
miss out on good wines.
But if the system
says buy this one,
you don't want it
to waste your time.
Well, that's a different
metric from accuracy.
That one is called precision.
Maybe on the other hand, you are
now past your graduate school
years and now you're really
worried about missing out
on the good, beautiful
wines you would have liked.
Well, now you're
after recall, which
is a different thing entirely.
Of all the beautiful ones
that were there how many did
it return correctly for me?
So you have to think about how
you want to measure success.
And then what you need to do--
going back to being
data driven, you
need to make sure that you can
be data driven at your launch
don't launch
decision at the end.
So you need to commit to your
minimum performance criterion.
If you picked accuracy,
where's your minimum cutoff
for letting the system
see the light of day?
Is it 80% accuracy?
Is it 70%?
But you must commit upfront.
And what you'll realize,
leaders, you can do all of this
without any data,
without any employees,
without any equations
or textbooks.
This is just you
meditating in a closet.
And so everyone
who's listening here,
you can now start thinking about
what would you label if you
had an awesome thing labeler?
And so you can all
get started on this.
And if anyone asks you, are
you doing machine learning?
You can, with a completely clear
conscience, say, absolutely.
Yes, I am.
Because you are
doing the right first
step in the applied process.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Off of that note,
is there any additional advice
that you would have, especially
for the data science teams?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So I find
myself repeating three words
over and over.
It's become a sort of slogan.
And that is split your data.
Data splitting is a way
that you can have your cake
and eat it too, in data science.
See, when we talked
about data driven
and we saw that if you've
already seen the data,
then, at best, your decision
based on that data will be data
inspired when I should
be driven by the data.
Because if you use
the data to decide
what question to ask of
the data well, you know,
you see what you get.
The trouble is you can't
use the same dataset
for both inspiration and
rigorous data driven decision
making.
So what's the quick hack?
Well, you've got one dataset.
You need more than one
dataset so turn one dataset
into more than one.
Into an exploratory
piece and a test piece.
That lets you have your
cake and eat it too.
Because now what you do is
you give the exploratory piece
to everyone in the
organization, no matter
their education level.
And everyone can go do some
descriptive analytics on it
and the 10 second lecture
on descriptive analytics
is plot all the things
but stay skeptical.
So you don't need a whole
lot of educational background
just have a look at
what's in the data.
And if you can't
look at all of it,
look at the first five entries.
That's better than nothing.
Just get inspired.
The only mistake you can
make during exploring data
is taking yourself
too seriously.
We humans are really
good at finding patterns.
We'll find Elvis in
a piece of toast.
And we shouldn't
take that seriously.
And so here you have
your entire organization
looking for tasty
tidbits of insight
in this exploratory set.
What they're sort of
doing is baiting a hook
that they're going to
fling into the ocean
where decision makers swim.
They're going to
try to get decision
makers to react to
that information
and make a decision.
And decision makers
will, for the most part,
completely ignore that plot
and make their decisions
some other way.
That's fine.
That's par for the course.
But every now and
then that data insight
makes the decision maker want
to bite and take an action.
And if that's not such a
very important decision well,
you know fling that
fish back into the ocean
and make the decision
based on inspiration.
That's fine.
We're allowed to make
decisions based on intuition
as long as we're honest
with ourselves about it.
But if that's a really
important decision,
then the decision
maker might not
want to run headlong into
the wall based on Elvis
found in a slice of toast.
They want to make sure that
this is something worth taking
seriously.
They want to approach
the decision rigorously.
Well, then they can
use that inspiration
to frame their decision context.
And that's really easy
to do because they
know what they were doing
before the insight came in.
They know how they thought
about changing their minds
in response to the data.
They know what it is
about it that made them
want to change their minds.
And then they can go
to the other dataset
and have their experts check
that it's actually worth
taking that action, that we
should take it seriously.
And statistics really is the
science of changing your mind.
So you'll bring
the statistician in
and see if it's worth
actually reacting
to that piece of insight.
So split your data.
Now why haven't people
been doing this all along?
So until fairly recently
it was hard enough
to scrape together enough data
for one respectably sized data
set, never mind more than one.
But now as the world is
generating more and more data,
most of our listeners
I think have no excuse
not to split their data.
You've got so much
don't be stingy.
Make two datasets.
Use one for inspiration
and use the other one
for making decisions well.
MARK MANDEL: So what would
you say to data scientists who
are worried about
exploring these datasets
but they don't necessarily
have that deep educational
background?
What do you suggest for
those sort of people?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Well,
look, exploration
is supposed to be sloppy.
We don't want to come
to conclusions here.
We don't want to take
ourselves too seriously.
Again, we're looking
at that piece of toast
and we're seeing if we
find Elvis in it or not.
This isn't the stage
where we get rigorous.
And so actually I'd
like to rather say
to data scientists
that think you need
a deep educational background
here to please calm
down a little bit and
not bully everyone else.
The skills that you
need for doing this bit
are exactly the
same skills that you
use for looking at photographs.
And by the way, photographs
are stored as data.
They're not stored as this
beautiful, visual thing
that you can make sense of.
And when you take those numbers
that photographs are stored
as and you visualize them
with appropriate software--
I don't know Paint or Google
Photos or what have you,
then you can begin
to get inspired.
But you must never take that
photograph too seriously.
If you just walk down
the street and you
find some photograph
lying around,
don't go learning all kinds
of things about the world
based on it.
You don't know anything
about where it came from.
The best that you can do is
say this is what is here.
And so as long as everyone
has the discipline
to plot it and stick to
well, what we learned
is that this is what's here
and maybe we might be inspired.
We shouldn't take
ourselves too seriously.
Let's not come to
conclusions until we've
gone to the other dataset.
Then it's fine.
So everyone should be
allowed in and empowered
to just go for it.
You already have
the right skills.
What you're doing with
digital photographs
it's what you should
be doing with all
the rest of the datasets.
The funny thing is though
that data scientists,
they have a habit many of them--
I keep saying "they"
I should say "we"
because I was guilty
of this when I just
finished my statistics
graduate training.
We spend a long time in school
getting a gold star every time
that we use the most
complicated tool in our arsenal.
And so when we leave
after years and years
of that reinforcement,
our comfort zone,
our natural behavior
is to keep doing
the most sophisticated
thing possible-- the most
rigorous thing possible.
And we even kid
ourselves that we
are saving, rescuing
decision makers in some way
because decision makers don't
even know that they need this.
Well, look, in the
exploratory phase,
taking ourselves too
seriously has no place.
So don't be rigorous
for its own sake there.
Take it lightly,
do things quickly.
And when we are moving
from the exploratory phase
to the data driven
decision making
phase in the other dataset,
that should be kicked off
by the decision maker.
And the decision
maker is the one
who's had the training
to think about, well,
how scared should we be?
How should we trade risk?
How important is this?
How much rigor is required?
Because they don't teach that
in a data science, computer
science, statistics
training program.
So everyone should be
allowed in and don't do rigor
for its own sake.
Decision makers should
kick off the rigor.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Great, I know we're
getting a little
short on time but I
wanted to give us
the chance to dive
in to just a couple things.
One question that definitely
comes to mind-- people
are interested in
decision intelligence.
What are some of the resources?
Where do you
recommend that they go
to start exploring this space?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: So decision
intelligence engineering
is a practice that we've
put a lot of effort
into developing at Google.
And we've got a lot of training
and resources internally
but there's not a lot
out there externally.
When I went about
getting my own training,
I had to have full
immersion in a whole lot
of separate degrees.
I had to study
statistics separately
from psychology separately
from economics separately
from neuroscience.
That's an awful lot
of schooling time.
Sometimes I think I wonder
about my life choices.
But we can't expect--
MELANIE WARRICK: Don't we all?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Right.
We can't expect everyone out
there who's interested in this
to go and pursue full
degrees on a whole bunch
of different disciplines.
So since there is not
that much out there
and we've been
developing it in here,
we've decided to start
sharing a lot of resources
with the world,
sharing what we know.
So stay tuned.
Watch this space.
There'll be a lot of information
about decision intelligence
coming soon.
MARK MANDEL: Follow
you on Twitter?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV:
Sure, if you like.
MELANIE WARRICK: Was there
anything else actually you
did want to say in terms
of decision intelligence
decision making that we
haven't had a chance to cover,
especially-- you've had
some wonderful analogies.
But was there anything else
you wanted to touch on?
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Yes.
I want to talk very briefly
about some challenges in AI.
When we move from a
research machine learning
to applied machine
learning as our focus,
we move from how
does the microwave
work so we can build
a better one to does
it work so that I can serve
my customers well and solve
my business problems?
Now, "how does it work?"
sounds easy but it isn't.
Because there are three things
we have to deal with there.
What does it mean to work?
What is "it" that
we're trying to do?
And that is on decision makers.
Then, the does it work?
That is on the
statisticians working
with the decision
makers actually
making sure that it delivers.
And the last bit, the
sort of hidden bit,
is that in any kitchen data
science kitchen as well
your ingredients matter.
On what ingredients
does it work?
If you put bad ingredients,
bad data in you
shouldn't expect good results
out on the other side.
What I like to say
about machine learning
is that the world represented
by your training data
is the only world that you
can expect to succeed in.
Think of your training data
little bit like textbooks
that your student
might study from.
Maybe you want to teach your
student, I don't know, calculus
and you've given them a bunch
of textbooks to learn from.
The examples in
those textbooks--
the world represented by
them is the only thing
that student's going to
learn from that process.
So just because you have
data, just because you
have textbooks doesn't
mean your students
are going to learn calculus.
Open that textbook
and check that what's
in there is calculus
and not, I don't know,
Japanese-English
vocabulary pairs.
Because your students going to
find some patterns in there,
sure, and stitch a recipe that
connects Japanese with English.
It just won't be
relevant to your task.
So your ingredients
really matter.
So please make sure
that you have thought
about what "it" is, that you
have checked that it does work
before you release it, and that
you've thought really carefully
about your ingredients.
And split your data.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's great.
Well, thank you.
Cassie, I appreciate
you joining us again
on the podcast especially to
give us this robust perspective
on decision intelligence.
Thank you, again.
CASSIE KOZYRKOV: Thanks so much.
It was a lot of fun to be here.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you again, Cassie,
for coming on the
show and talking to us
about decision intelligence.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, really
interesting conversation.
Super interested to hear
more about the research
that you're doing in this space.
MELANIE WARRICK: Agreed.
All right, Mark, how can
I secure my GCP account
using a YubiKey?
MARK MANDEL: So I'm
sure many of us--
or but if you haven't
that's totally fine--
have heard of say things like
two-factor authentication,
right?
So you want to have a password
for something, like a thing
you know and you want to have
a thing you have like say a--
MELANIE WARRICK:
Through your email or--
AOL GREETING VOICE:
You've got mail.
MELANIE WARRICK:
--sometimes it's a text
or it's a phone call.
[PHONE RINGS]
But it's your password
in combination
with something else.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And so there's also these
devices, like security keys
or you may have heard YubiKeys,
for physical devices that
can be used as a
two-factor authentication.
Basically it's that
thing you have.
MELANIE WARRICK: Some of
them are shaped almost
like a thumb drive.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: But they're
not a thumb drive in terms
of holding actual data on them.
But they're a way of
proving that you exist
and that you are next to the
device that you're using.
MARK MANDEL: What you
can do is basically
you can secure your Google Cloud
account that gives you access
to Google Cloud Platform using
all these actual options.
So you can actually
do it through--
you can have two-factor
authentication using
text messages; there's a
Google Authenticator, which
is a rolling number
that you can use
as a two-factor authentication
you have on your Android
and iOS devices; as well as
security keys themselves.
And we'll have a link in
the show notes describing
how you can do that.
But what ends up happening is
when you say do GCloud auth
login, so you're doing
a GCloud authentication
or you're trying to do
something through the console,
it asks you for
your two-factor auth
when you log in so that
your authentication has
that extra layer of security.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, and
YubiKeys in particular
are up and coming in
the security field.
So seen as more
secure in comparison
to like receiving a text.
So if you have the
opportunity, use that
and I know you can use that
on a number of different sites
that you can log in to,
like GitHub for example.
You should explore it.
Your Gmail-- but definitely look
at that for the Google Cloud.
Something else we wanted
to give a shout out to
is one of our community members.
Actually wrote a blog post--
not exactly the same thing
but still interesting
where he wanted to experiment
with encrypting his GCloud
credentials on his laptop
using a YubiKey and this
was from Salman Rashid.
And he basically explored--
he even says this in the
post, which is kind of great.
Is that this is not really
a practical use of it
but if you have application
credentials on your laptop
that you wanted
to try encrypting
with the YubiKey or smart card--
the GPG smart card
is the YubiKey
is my understanding
or close enough.
Anyway, he takes
you through steps
on how to do that
encryption and tells you
where to find the different
files and what files to change.
And we'll include
that link for those
who might be curious to
explore this and experiment
and play around with it and get
more comfortable with YubiKeys.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's pretty neat.
He really does-- he
kind of hacks GCloud
so that any time
he does a GCloud
operation he has to use
YubiKey and make sure it works.
MELANIE WARRICK: One thing
to stress that he points out
in his article
and you definitely
want to do this is
make copies and back up
the actual access tokens because
you will not want to lose those
if for some reason
your encryption works
but there's something that
gets broken along the way.
MARK MANDEL: Use
at your own risk.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Exactly, exactly.
And again, not
necessarily something
that you need to do but
also just sort of a fun,
experimental thing to play with.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
All right, Mark, you going to
go anywhere in the next month,
couple of months?
MARK MANDEL: So I will be
presenting at the monthly San
Francisco Game
Development Community
at the meet up here
in San Francisco.
So I will be doing that
on the 30th of May.
I'm doing my talk called you
can't just add more servers.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes, you can't.
MARK MANDEL: You can't.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, that's great.
You going to be speaking
every month on that?
MARK MANDEL: No.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Just next month?
MARK MANDEL: Just next month.
MELANIE WARRICK: Got it.
MARK MANDEL: What are you up to?
MELANIE WARRICK: Next
month I will-- on June 26
I will be speaking
at an event that's
being co-hosted by the women
in machine learning and data
science and Pie
Ladies at DoorDash.
So we will be doing a couple of
talks on careers and datasets.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, Melanie, thank you so
much for hanging out with me
for yet another podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]